مره اخرى يلوذ رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان بالقضاء لتفادي اعتقاله على خلفيه عده
قضايا تتعلق باتهامات بالارهاب والتحريض
على العنف والفساد وفيما نفع عمران خان
كافه الاتهامات الموجهه له شنه هجوما
لازعا على الحكومه التي اتهمها بالاستبداد
وعدم احترام القانون
انني مستعد للذهاب الى السجن لكنني لن
اقبل بهذا النظام المستبد وسوف اقاوم حتى
النهايه واقول للجميع ان لا يستسلموا لانه
في اليوم الذي تقبلون فيه هذا النظام
الضالم فلن يكون لكم ولا للدوله مستقبل او
بقاء لكن الخناقه بات يضيق شيئا فشيئا على
رئيس الوزراء السابق مع انشقاق العديد من
قاده حزبه واعلانه مع تشكيل حزب جديد بما
علاقه عمران خان بالمؤسسه العسكريه باتت
اكثر توترا في ظل تاكيد الجيش عزمه تضييق
الخناق القانونيا على مدبر ومخطط الهجمات
التي طالت مرافق تابعه له ورموزا وطنيه
اثناء تظاهرات لانصار عمران
لقد تم الكشف عن مؤامرات عمران خان
وانشطته المناهضه للدوله باوامر خارجيه
فهو لم يراعي المصالح الوطنيه والدفاعيه
والاقتصاديه بل سعى ضدها لكن لا يعود
بامكانه الان خداع الشعب مره اخرى
حصول عمران خان على كفالات ضد الاعتقال في
القضايا الموجهه ضده الا انها تظل مؤقته
ومشروطه بتعاونه مع التحقيقات فيما تنتظره
قضايا وبلغات اخرى جديده تؤكد الحكومه
الباكستانيه انها غير مسيسه ووفق القانون
في ظل الانشقاقات التي تعصف بحزب عمران
خان وتوتر علاقته مع المؤسسه العسكريه يرى
مراقبون ان عمران خان بات يعول على القضاء
لتفادي الاعتقال كما على انصاره في الشارع
الباكستاني لانقاذ المستقبل السياسي له
ولحسبه عبد الرحمن المزيني العربيه اسلام
اباد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات